in this video we'll be talking about
cell cycle checkpoints and this video is
quite detailed video so stay tuned till
the end and you would get a total
explanation about cell cycle
checkpoints now there are three cell
cycle checkpoints that we are going to
talk about this operates in g1s
transition G22 M transition and within
the M phase the first checkpoint that we
are going to talk about is g1s
transition checkpoint also known as the
Restriction point so in this particular
restriction point or in this checkpoint
cell assess its environment cell looks
for growth factor growth conditions and
understands whether it is optimal
condition for dividing or not also it
looks and monitors for the internal
damages like DNA damage so obviously
it's one of the most important
checkpoint or the DNA damage
checkpoint so imagine there is a DNA
damage that has accumulated in G1 phase
and in this phase if the DNA damage
persist then the consequence is
detrimental because there could be
replication blockage and there could be
faulty chromosome segregation eventually
that is why there should be checkpoints
which can possibly block the transition
of the cell
cycle and this would give the cell
enough time to repair its damage that is
why g1s checkpoint is really useful
let's see how this checkpoint operates
at the molecular
level so the cell has to First sense the
DNA damage then pause the cell cycle
give the give give itself enough time to
repair the damage and then again resume
the cell cycle so one of the key thing
that the cell has to do right now is to
pause the cell cycle and that can happen
in several ways but before that cell
senses the DNA damage with specific DNA
damage sensors like like ATM ATR Etc so
all of these are kyes molecules so which
can phosphorate Downstream Target such
as cze 2 and cheze 1 kyes now cze 2 kyes
actually phosphates p53 which is a tumor
suppressor protein its inherent goal is
to suppress the cell cycle
anyway phosphorilated p-53 is free and
it cannot be degraded generally under
normal circumstances p-53 would be
degraded
and basically
mdm2 degrades the p53 in ubiqutin
proteosome mediated pathway but when
there is a damage happening in the DNA
p- 53's goal is to stay protected and
then prevent further damage so p-53
would perform specific task p-53
activates p21 which is a cycl dependent
kyes
inhibitor so it would inhibit cyclan cdk
complexes thereby pausing the cell cycle
progression from G1 to
S now let us quickly recap and resume so
p-53 would pause the cell cycle give it
enough time to repair the DNA for
example via homologous recombination
based repair the cell would try to
basically repair the damage but imagine
the damage is not repairable then what
happens in that case
the cell would choose the hard way of
undergoing apoptosis it is better not to
segregate a faulty chromosome than dying
because once these M mutations
accumulate in the genome it would
increase the risk of tumor
formation okay so now we understand what
really happens in the DNA damage
checkpoint in the g1s transition so
basically just to summarize DNA damages
are sensed by kyes which recruit p-53 p
53 further activates cycl dependent kyes
Inhibitors and thereby cyclines are
inhibited so cyclan D cdk4 complex which
operate at G1 phase is inhibited and
second cycline e cdk2 which is important
for S phase transition is also blocked
as a result the entry into the S phase
is blocked so the cell cannot move from
G1 to S
phase so this is the goal of G1 s
checkpoint so these are the summarized
point for g1s checkpoint anyway prb
which is another tumor suppressor
protein plays critical role in this
checkpoint as well I have a different
video on prb click on the IE button to
get that video now next we talk about
the g2m check point as the name suggests
it operates in the g2m transition point
but what does it look for it looks for
DNA damage Point number one and point
number two it looks for unreplicated DNA
so basically if the replication doesn't
happened properly in the S phase and
there is some sort of unreplicated DNA
that can also be sensed using this
checkpoint and even after replication
there is some damage which requires or
let's say there is some mutation DNA
break that occur during the replication
phase that can also be sensed using this
checkpoint so let's see how this
checkpoint operates at a molecular level
so entry from G2 to M phase this
particular uh transition requires the
activity of cyclan B and cdk one this is
the mitotic cycline now any DNA damage
would anyway be sensed with molecular
senses like ATM ATR that can activate
Che 1 kyese which inhibits
cdc25 now cdc25 is a crucial phosphatase
that activates the cyclan B cdk1 cdk1
complex so obviously when cdc25 is
inhibited with the help of Che one
kyes then this activation step is
abrogated one cycling B cdk1 is not
activated the transition from G2 to M
phase cannot happen moreover Che 1 kyes
can also phosphorate p-53 which
activates p21 and thereby the cyclan B
cdk1 activity can actually be
inhibited now this is really crucial
because if there is DNA breakage or
unreplicated DNA it's not wise to enter
the mhase and condense the chromosome
because again we know when the separ
would happen there could be a faulty
separation that is detrimental for the
cell that is why pausing the cell again
recruiting the repair Machinery at this
point is again
important then we talk about the mhase
checkpoint which obviously operates in
the mhase more precisely in the
metaphase and the anaphase
transition now the cell ensures at this
point that chromosomes are properly
aligned in the spindle fibers because
before the divis division or segregation
of the chromosome this alignment is
important proper tension has to be
sensed at this point otherwise
segregation would be unequal so this
checkpoint helps to prevent any errors
in chromosome distribution in the
daughter cells so what happens in the
anaphase is chromosome segregation and
this is a tightly regulated process
because a defective segregation might
lead to detrimental consequences now in
the L metaphys what happens is there are
anaphase promoting complex which
generally inhibits securin and basically
separase is now free so separas can
actually separate these structural
maintenance of chromosome proteins and
once these proteins are gone the
chromosomes now can be separated
properly and that really happens in
during the anaphase State this is the
normal scenario let's see if there is an
unequal tension so this tension tension
sensing is really important so this is
the normal situation and let's say there
is an unequal tension so there are bunch
of tens tension sensors sitting near the
region of the Kinto cor and that can
trigger the activation of many molecules
such as mad one mad 2 so these mad
proteins are
actually important sensors that can
inhibit APC now if APC is inhibited that
there is nobody to degrade securin now
once securin is not degraded securin
holds the separas complex and separas
complex cannot separate it and thereby
the chromosome separation doesn't happen
at this point so again it waits till
this tension normalize and then the
segregation happens so this would ensure
an equal segregation of
chromosome now this concept that we
discussed all the checkpoints are nicely
described in the uh molecular biology of
the cell by Harve Lish and all these
concepts are taken from this book so you
can quickly visit that chapter and take
a quick revision so I hope this video
was useful if you like this video give
it a quick thumbs up you can get more
notes and flash cards in our Facebook
page or Instagram page you can support
our Channel using super TRS you can pay
via PTM PayPal or UPI see you in next
video